how did you figure you were gonna start
a car company and be successful at it
well I didn't really think Tesla would
be successful I thought we would most
likely fail but I thought that we at
least could address the false perception
that people had that an electric car had
to be ugly and slow and and boring like
a golf cart
but you say you didn't expect the
company to be successful then why try if
something's important enough you should
try even if you probable outcome is
failure we focus on on signal over noise
a lot of companies get confused they
they spend money on things that don't
actually make the product better for
example at Tesla we've we've never spent
any money on advertising we put all the
money into R&D and manufacturing and
design to try to make the car as good as
possible and I think that's that's the
way to go before for any given company
just keep thinking about are these
efforts that people are expending are
they resulting in a better product or
service if they're not stop those
efforts you just watch too amazing clip
some Elon Musk take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how to apply them to your business and
your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]